it's time to go plus
ultra because the fifth season of my
hero academia is currently on air while
we watch the exploits of our heroes and
see what new direction the series heads
off in it sounds like just the time for
a recap of the top 10 badass my hero
academia moments and mha
as you know it is full of badass moments
with its diverse characters and their
quirks fun story and engaging action
sequences this anime now counts among
the top shonen anime currently running
there's a lot to like
especially the tournament style arcs and
rivalries among characters heck
if you're old enough watching it might
just make you fine for those old school
days given that this is a battle shonen
our pick of badass moments mostly
comprises epic battles and one-on-one
fights but you might be surprised to
find more than a few emotional moments
that leave a deep impact on the overall
storyline so let's get right to it here
are the top 10 badass my hero academia
moment
starting off it's red riot and fat gum
vs rapper and dengai
this is one of the best fights of season
four and that's saying something for a
battle heavy arc what makes this contest
fantastic
is not just the action of music but a
backstory that turns a likeable
character into everyone's best
boy backed into a corner girishima's old
doubts about his worth as a pro hero and
his quirks start to haunt him again
leaving him unable to fight even before
the battle started but old wounds also
bring clarity
about why he wanted to be a hero in the
first place and how hard he struggled to
become one
burning with a new intensity kirishima
transforms into red riot unbreakable
becoming an indestructible shield for
his partner fat gum
and turning defeat into victory it's the
greatest hour yet for this brave and
loyal
young hero
oh
despite his lazy appearance and general
air of disinterest the homeroom teacher
is more than adept at taking on an
entire gang of enemies by himself
as we see when the league of villains
attacks ua high school is ability to
cancel his opponent's quirks simply by
looking at them is a powerful weapon but
it's his prowess of physical combat that
comes as a surprise he might seem to
lack the energy to utter even a few
words of encouragement to his class
but he can easily leap off heights
sucker punch opponents much bigger than
him tie them up with his scarf
and keep the attacks coming his ability
to tolerate extreme pain is impressive
as is his keen intellect which allows
him to plan his moves even when in full
flight he might look and sound like a
slouch
but this is one guy you know you can
count on if you ever find yourself in a
pinch
one is an arrogant scowling hot head and
delinquent the other
a timid polite intelligent dreamer chalk
and cheese
they're the series great rivals the
competition between the two goes back to
their childhood and is only intensified
with adolescents of all of their
confrontations the most memorable
perhaps is when bakulgo challenges deku
to a late night fight in season three
honesty hits harder than anything else
and that's what this contest shows us
for the first time
bakugo shows deku and us his true
feelings his jealousy towards him his
admiration of and regret towards all
might it's also the first time we see
him treat theirku as an equal instead of
lashing out in anger or walking off in a
huff as he usually does
bakugo bears his heart and soul and deku
responds with empathy and honesty
emotionally charged it might be but this
fight also has some great action
it perfectly captures why these two
polar opposites bring so much to the
series
[Music]
another emotional moment makes the cut
at number seven
in the heroes fight against overhaul in
the fourth season muriel demonstrates
why he might have become a worthy
successor to all might had their coup
not come along
showing excellent mastery of his quirk
permeation and incredible hand-to-hand
combat abilities murio proves more than
capable of taking on the overpowered
villain the two put on a brilliant show
of skills that surely would have
deserved a spot on this list had it not
been for what comes after which makes
even more of an impact
even as he's winning his battle against
overhaul mirio chooses to take a quirk
erasing bullet meant for erie and save
the little girl
losing his quirk in the process it's a
devastating loss and yet he faces up to
it with a good natured smile promising
eerie he'll be her hero forever just
goes to show that being a hero isn't
only about having heavenly abilities and
that a badass moment can have you
sobbing into your tissues
that brings us to the deku overhaul
fight that follows right after which
takes the number six spot given that
this is the climactic fight of season
four we get to see deku at his most
powerful
using one for all at full power and he
does so without sustaining any damage to
his body thanks to erie finally
gathering the courage to use her unique
quirk
check out any online forum and the fight
with overhaul is bound to rank high
on all-time great mha fights it's also
one of deku's best fights
ever throughout the series we're used to
seeing the boy who was born quirkless
struggle first with adapting to his new
power
then with learning to use it and then
again with trying to gain some kind of
mastery of it his exploits against
overhaul give us a glimpse of just what
he might accomplish in the future as all
might's chosen air and the next symbol
of peace it's an epic battle and it's
the most badass deku who has ever been
now just like the myhero academia world
the internet's filled with villains
with lots of hacking scams and greedy
corporates
saying no to fun with the dreaded region
locks you've got to arm yourself and
keep up with the times
and our sponsor expressvpn is here to be
your swiss army knife
in the treacherous sea that is the
internet with expressvpn's amazing
service
you can connect to so many different
proxy servers from all over the world
i've used it to watch anime like hunter
hunter and jeebly movies
and now even use it to watch my hero
academia on netflix
all you have to do is open up expressvpn
and select the uk server and
boom your netflix just went plus ultra
there are so many vpn options out there
but nothing can even match expressvpn in
terms of safety
convenience and plain ease of use and i
can teach you how to avail of such an
amazing service
all you have to do is click the link
below and a veil of the free 3 month
service there's no better time to jump
in than now so make sure to check out
the link below or go to expressvpn.com
vinnie tube and get your hands on your
strongest and most reliable buddy on the
internet
it's another deku moment at the halfway
mark this time it's his battle against
that big chunk of meat and muscle that
is
muscular this villain lives up to his
name with his ability to manipulate his
muscles to augment his physicality and
strength to superhuman levels
although a minor antagonist he's by far
one of the strongest members of the
league of villains in terms of physical
strength what's more he has a nasty
disposition even for a villain
showing pleasure in killing for the sake
of killing even children are fair game
too
in a situation where deku not only has
to fight him but keep the young goddard
safe from him
it seems like the worst possible match
up and it goes along predictable lines
with muscular toying with deku push to
bone shattering limits there goes all
about out for the count
but heroes don't die so easy and a tiny
moment of inspiration gives him that
little extra push
seeing they could find extra reserves of
strength where they ought to be none is
truly breathtaking
and badass
know my hero academia top 10 video would
be complete without our main man
almighty in action his battle against
nomu during the school infiltration arc
in the first season comes in at number
four
artificially created nomu is still a top
tier villain
engineered to counter the number one pro
hero at 100
and all might at that time is a shadow
of his former self
but like i said before power isn't all
there is to being a hero going that
extra distance comes naturally to them
as all mike demonstrates with his
hard-fought but confident victory over
nomu moving at lightning speed and
hitting him with a barrage of punches
all might gives the monster no time to
regenerate what makes this moment badass
is that it introduces us to the number
one hero and symbol of peace as a
warrior
all might shows us why he's a legend and
the hope of an entire generation
even if he's nowhere near his best it's
also a moment that makes it clear that
the time to pass on the torch and give
the world a new hero
is near
with his striking hair celebrated
lineage pure talent and difficult
backstory there was never any doubt that
todoroki would be a fan favorite he gets
his most memorable moment perhaps in the
sports festival arc when his fight
against deku leads him to unleash his
fiery side till that tournament dodoroki
had never used his firepower out of
resentment towards his father choosing
to rely solely on his ice abilities but
he's convinced to accept his left side
by deku and the strange connection he
feels with him this is a contest
brimming with newfound rivalry and
friendship
admiration envy and mutual respect it
pushes the reserve cool kid to
passionately reveal his innermost
feelings to everyone's surprise
including his own it's exhilarating to
see the flames burst out for the very
first time this moment manages not only
to be totally badass
but also convey some of the best growth
stories in anime the developments
are also a testament to their guru's
inspiring personality
kim
from son to father taking the second
spot is endeavour earning his stripes as
the new number one pro hero
as well as the grudging admiration of
mha fans
to quite a few the highlight of season
four is the battle between endeavour and
hood with the winged hawks playing
sidekick to the fire-powered hero a lot
of fans dislike endeavour and for good
reason too he's been a terrible father
to todoroki and a first-class jerk to
everyone else but this battle puts him
in a new light
giving it his all to save his colleagues
and the people from hood and upgraded an
extremely dangerous nomu
endeavour proves to a skeptical world
that he might not be or might but is a
worthy replacement that they can count
on the clash is brutal
emotional and epic while he manages to
eventually overpower
his opponent with his quirk prominence
burn he ends up sustaining heavy damage
making this moment even more important
is the fact that it's a critical
milestone in the series making not only
the beginning of an era without all
might
but also quite possibly endeavour's path
to redemption
now that brings us to the most badass
moment in my hero academia
it happens during the legendary clash
between all might and all for one the
battle between the world's greatest hero
and its greatest villain when all for
one the shadowy figure pulling the
strings of the league of villains
finally goes up against
all might his true intention might have
been to destroy his longtime rival
but instead he ends up pushing all might
beyond his limits desperate to do his
duty
the number one hero musters every last
bit of strength he has left in him to
bring out his most powerful
attack yet the united states of smash
all for one is soundly defeated but this
victory can only be called
a tragedy no longer able to carry on the
world's symbol of peace and with his
true self no longer a secret
all might hangs up his hero's cape
forever but even in that final moment
when he reverts to his real weakened
form
all might remains a symbol of courage
and hope to his fans and admirers
and there you have it the top 10 badass
my hero academia moments
what do you think did any of your
favorites make the cut leave me a
comment and let me know
if you like this video press like and
show it some love you can also check out
my other videos on vinnie tube and
if you'd like subscribe to my channel
too don't forget to check out our
sponsors of this video
expressvpn bypass all those pesky region
locks and even browse sites not
available in your region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now
thanks for staying till the end and i'll
see you soon with a brand new video